hi my name is Aparna I am a Shopaholic
and I'm addicted to online returns well
at least I was at one time I had two or
three packages of clothing delivered to
me every other day I would intentionally
buy the same item in a couple different
sizes and many colors because I did not
know what I really wanted so i over
ordered I tried things on and then I
sent what didn't work back once my
daughter was watching me return some of
those packages back and she said mom I
think you have a problem I didn't think
so
I mean it's free shipping and free
returns right I didn't even think twice
about it until I heard a statistic at
work that shocked me you see I'm a
global solutions director for top tier
retail and we were in a meeting with one
of my largest customers discussing how
to streamline costs one of their biggest
concerns was managing returns just this
past holiday season alone they had 7.5
million pieces of clothing returned to
them I could not stop thinking about it
what happens to all these returned
clothes so I came home and researched
and I learned that every year 4 billion
pounds of return the clothing ends up in
the landfill
that's like every resident in the US did
a load of laundry last night and decided
to throw it in the trash today I was
horrified I'm like of all people I
should be able to help prevent
my job is to find solutions to
logistical issues like these not create
them so this issue became very personal
to me I said you know what we have to
solve this and we can with some of the
existing systems we already have in
place and then I started to wonder how
did we get here I mean it was only like
six years ago when a study recommended
offering free online returns would drive
customers to spend more we started
seeing companies offering free online
returns to drive more sales and provide
a better experience what we didn't
realize is that this would lead to more
items being returned as well in the US
companies lost 351 billion dollars in
sales in 2017 alone retailers are
scrambling to recover their losses they
tried to place that return item online
to be sold again or they'll sell it to a
discount partner or a liquidator
basically if companies cannot find a
place for this item quickly and
economically its place becomes the trash
suddenly I felt very guilty for being
that shopper somebody who contributes to
this who would have thought my innocent
shopping behavior would be hurting not
only me but our planet as well and as I
thought about what to do I kept thinking
why does the item have to be returned to
the retailer in the first place what if
there was another way a win-win for
everyone
what if when a person is trying to
return something but it could go to the
next shopper who wants it and not the
retailer what if instead of a return
they could do what I call a green turn
consumers could use an app to take
pictures of the item and verify the
condition while returning it artificial
intelligence systems could then sort
these clothes by condition mint
condition or slightly used and directed
to the next appropriate person mint
conditioned clothes could automatically
go to the next buyer while slightly used
clothes could be marked down and offered
online again the retailer can decide the
business rules on the number of times a
particular item can be resold all that
the consumer would need to do is obtain
a mobile code take it to the nearest
shipping place to be packed and shipped
and off it goes from one buyer to the
next not the landfill now you will ask
what people really go through all this
trouble I think they would if they had
incentives like loyalty points or
cashback let's call it green cash there
would be a whole new opportunity to make
money from this new customer base
looking to buy these returns this system
would make a fun thing like shoppings a
spiritual experience that helps save our
planet
this is doable and we'll probably take
six months to weave some of an existing
systems and run a pilot even before any
of these logistical systems are in place
each of us shoppers can act now if every
single adult in the US made a few small
changes to our shopping behavior take
the extra time to research and think do
I really need this item no do I really
want this item before making a purchase
and if every one of us adults in the
u.s. returned five less items this year
we would keep 245 million pounds of
clothes out of the landfill six percent
reduction just like that this
environmental problem that we have
created is not thousands of years away
it's happening today and must stop now
to prevent growing landfills across the
globe
I want to leave my daughter and my
daughter's daughter a better and cleaner
place than I found it so I have not only
stopped or over-ordering I recycled
religiously as well and you can too it's
not difficult before we fill our
shopping carts and our landfills with
extra items that we don't want let's
pause
next time we are shopping online and
think twice about what we all hopefully
really do want a beautiful earth to call
home thank you
[Applause]